evangeline brush is here sister wives
star
maddie brown brush is opening up about
her daughter's health
revealing that her one-year-old daughter
evangeline had her foot
amputated the 24 year old reality star
shared the news on instagram monday
posting this pic with her baby girl from
the hospital
that's maddie with her little one whose
left leg and right arm are bandaged
maddie explained in the caption quote
evie received some
major gifts for her first birthday her
surgeon laid the groundwork for her new
foot and mobility it will bring
by way of a void amputation maddie also
explained that evie had
surgery to clip some webbing on her
right hand
too evie was diagnosed before birth with
oligodactyly a congenital anomaly
defined as the presence of fewer than
five fingers on a hand
when she was born they discovered she
was missing three fingers and a toe
one leg was missing a fibula commonly
known as the calf bone
she also had a bowed tibia and some of
her fingers were fused together
but maddie said her little girl has
returned home from the hospital
and is recovering beautifully after the
procedures
axel's doing really good as a big
brother he loves
evangeline doesn't want to let her go
but at the same time
he wants to start playing with her so it
lets me know as a parent we're doing
something right maddie who also shares
three-year-old son
axel james with her husband caleb
celebrated her daughter's
first birthday on august 20th with a
sweet tribute
on instagram posting this pic of evie
smiling at the beach
and calling her a little spitfire ray of
sunshine
in the caption we wanted to say a huge
thank you to everyone
yes thank you been so supportive all the
love
we appreciate it so much yes we love you
guys and
we appreciate everything